while the new york bar co-owner who
defied pandemic restrictions now facing
charges for allegedly ramming his car
into a sheriff's deputy
danny presti's lawyer says his client
believed his life was in danger
releasing this video of the incident
presti says the officers
did not identify themselves laura ingall
is live for us in staten island new york
and laura what else
is presti saying in his defense
you know he's saying trace that he
didn't do anything wrong when it comes
to that incident with the sheriff's
deputies because
he truly thought that he was in fear for
his life now we're standing outside of
the pub right now this is max
public house so the new york city
sheriff's deputies say that they were
observing presti and his crew
saturday night people coming and going
not through this front entrance but
through a
side entrance but then just after
midnight
they say that presti came out the front
door and started walking
down this block you can see it's just
about a half block away
and then right when he turned the corner
that is when the incident
went down with sheriff's deputies now
presti's attorney providing this video
of the incident
the new york city sheriff says that the
two officers identified themselves
before presti ran inside his jeep
hitting and then carrying the deputy on
the hood of the car about 100 yards
presti claims that the two people
dressed in dark clothing
never identified himself his attorney
says that presti
feared for his life and thought he was
about to be robbed or
jumped he doesn't slam
into whoever's on the hood of the car he
slowly starts to drive away with the
hopes
that the people that are attacking him
are going to get out of the way
the new york city sheriff had a
different take saying in part two
uniformed deputies identified themselves
and approached mr presti and attempted
to take him into custody
for the multiple criminal offenses
observed at that time presti began to
flee on foot
toward his vehicle the pursuing
uniformed deputies ordered him to stop
but he failed to comply and entered his
vehicle now the bar has been the site of
protests after owners declared it an
autonomous zone refusing to close even
after their liquor license
was suspended for ignoring the state's
coveted restrictions
and presti's attorney told me earlier
this morning they plan on having a chat
later today on the phone and then they
will get their ducks in order as they
proceed to fight
these charges and try and get this bar
reopened trace
laura ingall live for us on staten
island laura thank you